ragazzi miei oggi vi parlo di un altra
storia di quelle top al mondo proprio di
quelle che tipo tipo la mia prima volta
ancora peggio però questa qua ragazzi
risale a circa tre anni fa più o meno
racconto perché merita è un po strong
certo punti se siete più piccoli di
vabbè lasciamo per allora ero single
come adesso ed è successa una roba un po
particolare allora era il periodo
ragazzi dove faceva abbastanza video con
con i mets c'erano un po che facevamo
video insieme quindi ci sentivamo spesso
di adesso eccetera no una persona tra
tra tra i mensa ha un ruolo fondamentale
in questa storia il signor stefano lepri
step di un giorno viene da me mi dice ma
guarda lo so che c'è una c'è una ragazza
qua a firenze alla quale piace insomma
la quale piace mi ha detto questa cosa
qua io ho detto ma dai fa mi fa vedere
insomma di chi stiamo parlando è il sì
com'era dopo che mi ha fatto delle foto
era bastata grazioso detto vedrai sono
timido ma facciamo questo sforzo
incredibile di riuscire a socializzare
con qualcuno alle passali numero
vediamoci messaggi un fogliettino
stefano mi dà il numero e ci sentiamo
noi iniziamo a scriverci volevamo le
piede meno bla bla bla boia de e poi ha
scelto butto detto abete andiamo a
conoscere questa ragazza dynamo a
conoscerla non mi ricordo il paese
preciso mi pare fosse potrei dire una
cagata perché non mi ricordo di preci
però mi pareva fosse poggi bonsi ma
potrei dire una cagata ragazzi non me lo
ricordo bene se qualcuno egli poggibonsi
ecco sono stato a poggi bonsi prendo il
treno per arrivare da lei ovviamente
stava parlando di campagne toscane
quindi in mezzo alle colline in mezzo al
nulla più o meno arriva a prendermi
stazione ci vediamo
lei mi dice ok vieni che ho parcheggiato
la macchina
nel tragitto treno macchina non ha
spiccicato parola forse perché era
timidina anche lei ma lo ero anche io
quindi immaginate che conversazioni
incredibili tra due timidi
la conversazione è stata proprio a un
parcheggiato la macchina dietro la
stazione io ok ok andiamo
sì sì andiamo basta niente basta
lei accende la radio partono le canzoni
di martin garics no che lei aveva nel
suo cd marra chiavetta barra qualsiasi
cosa fosse perché che culo con
martingala quello che piace a me
incredibile niente finisce martin garics
parte una canzone di bard a casa dei
pentatoniche ma non mi ha anche
inventato ris mi piacciono che culo
finisce la canzone diventa tonic se
parte una canzone di un altro artista
che mi piaceva un sacco adesso non mi
ricordo di nicola di bari ma che curò
anche questo mi piace dopo un po che
partivano solo canzoni di gente che mi
piaceva ho capito è detto che ha preso
tutti gli artisti che mi piacevano e s'è
fatta la chiavetta apposta ma l'ho
capito solo dopo meno non farlo capire
cioè se metti una canzone dei vent a
toni se metti in altri g alessi ma che
ne so cioè non farlo capire che hai
fatto la chiavetta apposta a certo punto
di macchina gliel'ho pure detto m'hai
fatto lega la chiavetta di canzoni che
piacciono solo a me apposta e lei mi fa
no no no no no arriviamo a casa sua ha
detto la roba sull'attaccapanni noto una
particolarità di questa cucina c'era il
frigo che aveva sopra delle calamite del
duce dice guevara o a scelta delle ditte
dice che mara attaccata al frigo e di
cibo va bene le insidie three però
perché nelle cavi dice che va sul frigo
io la prima cosa che ho pensato è stata
vaio dove sono finito qua c'è dove sofid
perché sono qui
vado a a mille chilometri da casa mia a
casa di una ragazza che ha delle
calamite dice che vara nel frigo ha
fatto proprio questo cioè appoggio
appoggio giubbotto non tirò fuori il
telefono faccio la foto al frigo e alle
carabi tela mando
iscrivendovi ma da chi cazzo mi hai
mandato se ma non mi risponde con una
risata lunga un chilometro e io va bene
non solo aspettare anche stefano
ministro però io ma vabbè ma chi se ne
frega dai fa niente mettiamo le robe a
posto fateli la insomma iniziamo un po a
parlottare meglio di prima prova si fa
più o meno ora di cena tra una
chiacchiera e l'altra tra parentesi io
dovevo dormire lì tra l'altro che io ho
detto a me magari friends un albergo e
no no no vieni a casa mia io maschio e
tirchio detto va bene così non spendo i
soldi marchio nell'albergo a cena
andiamo a prendere la pizza mente
prendiamo la pizza levice anche perché
non prendiamo un film a noleggio che ce
lo guardiamo io non prendevo film a
noleggio da quando avevo 5 anni da
blockbuster abbiamo noleggiato un film e
siamo andati a casa equa ragazzi è
successa una cosa incredibile
mangiava la pizza ci mettiamo sul divano
iniziamo a guardare il film io non so
come dirvi questa cosa noi iniziamo a
guardare il film e io ero sempre un po
rigidi non ho perché comunque insomma
sono timido lei era era appoggiata era
era appoggiata tipo sulla mia spalla
a un certo punto lei inizia a non
guardare più il film ea rispondere a dei
messaggi al telefono a un certo punto
iniziano a mandarle anche dei voca lino
che lei ascolta le avvicina al telefono
all'orecchio e ascolta quindi in modo
che io non potessi sentire quello che
stai dicendo
a un certo punto le arriva un vocale lei
schiaccia per ascoltare il vocale ma non
fa in tempo a metterselo all'orecchio e
io dal vocale sento a tutto volume
questa frase io non posso farlo uguale
perché non solo toscano e va beh lì era
fatto e toscana di ragazze toscan si
capisce una sega boia e stasera si
tromba
gli ho sentito questa frase
ragazzi io vi giuro io vi giuro
ero così
e lei ha accidentalmente quando è
partita questa frase lei ha fatto finta
di niente c'è proprio l'associazione è
stata questa da essa tela si tromba c'è
non gliene fregava niente ha fatto finta
completamente in come se io non me ne
fossi accorto
lei ha sperato in sé che io potessi non
aver ascoltato nella frase lima è
impossibile non sentirla impossibile
alla fine non s'è concluso nulla perché
quella situazione lì e mi ha anche reso
addirittura molto più insicuro ecco che
tu dici vabbè non dovresti esserlo visto
che a quel punto si era capito ma io ero
molto piccola è anche adesso sarei così
sono molto timido io però mamma mia che
è stata avete la situazione tra le più
kringe della mia vita e poi niente il
giorno dopo sono tornato a casa sono
tornato a milano e ho picchiato stefano
allora da non è per il mio appuntamento
peggiore ma realtà non è peggiore perché
non è che è successo nel sia successo
chissà che cosa però il mio appuntamento
più kringe ecco il mio appuntamento più
kringe ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
questo era un altro racconti incredibili
e le cose che mi sono successe e ben
sono successe anche altre però quello
che racconto più avanti iscrivetevi al
canale li schiacciano dalla campanellina
così rimanete aggiornati sui video che
escono perché come fate a perderli
questi tipi di video io non lo so ma
adesso ho notato che avevo la luce dello
studio accesa
quindi sì c'è una luce spara flashata in
faccia vabbè giampiero metti un po a
posto se i nostri siti iscrivetevi era
ci vediamo come sempre al prossimo video
da ragazzi
[Musica]